et culture à présent est la tournée
européenne de rock the ballet tu pas ce
vendredi soir au palais des congrès de
tours sur scène dix danseurs qui
revisite les classiques du rock dans un
mélange de danse classique et de hip hop
et parmi eux mathis joubert un danseur
autodidacte originaire de belles château
et qui vit maintenant à new york juste
avant de se produire sur scène aurélie
renault l'a rencontré
hier la troupe a joué en région
parisienne le bus vient d'arriver à
touré pour mathis et sa compagne thaïs
également danseuse c'est le grand jour
c'est la dague plus importante c'est
vraiment celle que j'attends c'est qu'on
attendait depuis hier depuis le début la
tournée rue matisse a intégré la troupe
il y a quelques mois
rock the ballet est un phénomène avec
plus d'un million de spectateurs dans le
monde en disant dix danseurs qui
performe sur les plus grands tubes des
stones joue de michael jackson mais
l'histoire entre la danse et mathis
remonte à son enfance adolescence dans
sa chambre le jeune homme s'entraîne
devant des tutoriels sur youtube en
cinquième il crée son premier spectacle
de hip hop pour le collège la passion
est là et mathis intègre un lycée
proposant la filière danse à 16 ans il
débute sa formation de balle et puis
s'installe à new york aujourd'hui ils
dansent dans le monde entier mais à
quelques heures de la montée sur scène
l'émotion est là ce soir sa famille et
ses proches seront dans le public j'ai
appris hier même ce matin que le
directeur du collège donc qui m'avait
donné la permission de créer un groupe
de danse vient ce soir j'étais vraiment
surpris et super ravie c'est une fierté
c'est hyper gratifiant pour lui je sens
qu'il est très émue que ce soir ça va
être ça va être incroyable pour lui le
ballet break est un mélange de ballet
classique et de breakdance la spécialité
du couple de danseurs mathis et thaïs
vont faire le tour du monde mais dans
quelques années il aimerait transmettre
leur art aux plus jeunes se voient a
créé notre compagnie crée notre
compagnie développer ce style de the
ballet break et et apporter cette touche
tout ce qu'on a appris en amérique et
ailleurs le rapporter en france le
partager avec avec des petits garçons et
petites filles
qui meurent d'envié d'apprendre comme je
l'étais dans petite campagne apple
château dans un village de d'à peine 500
habitants et le couple n'exclut pas
l'idée d'installer cette compagnie à
tour